walk down to this video playing the
national master check car off 100 team
argentina all this guy's got like 10,000
five-minute games and i only played him
once okay we have a room let's see what
line ok one of the sidelines with D for
this is this is one of those lines where
you always think yeah well should have
looked this up I mean it's not
particularly great but you can easily
forget the lines 594 and now it's b5 i
guess ii five and then you take on e5 I
think if i'm not mistaken yeah this is
an online it's not particularly great
for white but you can easily easily
forget what's what's right this should
be 786 the issue i'm here for what is of
course that blacks got the bishops still
he's got some temporary activity
Bishop g5 might threaten on g7 I can
play d6 but yeah why it's not bad these
696 take stakes yeah but that's not very
inspiring and I'm spending lots of time
here many come a plane plane overlooking
move how could we be three attacking b7
attacking f7 hmm okay you maybe can take
now very shaky stuff very shaky stuff
how do i activate may be here page six
if it takes Bishop takes that's really
annoying pin so it probably needs to
retreat the bishop and I have gained age
six now at least rook be six sound this
is probably never really good
what about night g-form trying to try to
get I can Bishop takes rook takes at
this as 95 this is my again I have 95 as
a possible way to activate I'm
threatening to take and play Queen aged
four with a double attack maybe this is
not so bad this is also the answer to 95
just take and play Queen edge form may
be awesome taking Queen f6 can be an
idea yeah for instance in this snow it's
not not on the c6 the queen is sound
protecting the 95 is not really helping
yeah yeah 195 didn't it doesn't help i
mean the Queen retreats a lender snipe
d5 I probably need to need to allow that
here this lots of a pawn it's not not
great at all yeah those side lights are
always a bit tricky and there are you
could have maybe taken on f7 or played
some some some improvements there yeah
Queen to f1 what a move yeah but it's
not bad like to my cam on manly to any
two-bit crook I am coming to c 6 yeah
that's it's just a pawn he just took a
six and run the story of that game
yeah rook e8 andy sixx is probably wrong
I some day I've forgotten how how this
is how this is played it's played
surprisingly off in this line but
obviously I'm if it is working in a
practical game you can try all kinds of
stuff I'm not sure that this is such
great technical play but I know it's not
it's not great at all what is he doing
here look to you 193 m losers yeah it's
very lucky rookie three community 3
still keeps keeps things so within
within bounds yeah
yeah he keeps the break he keeps her he
didn't they don't lose immediately what
you really should but he doesn't okay so
see three rock t5 I mean it's I've made
some progress but not really enough yeah
my look on c5 isn't a great piece but at
least I'm not materially down or
anything like that
well well this could have could have
been much much worse check okay I five
pawns myself this is uh this isn't clear
at all let's see I don't have time I
don't have any time okay let's let's
March them let's March March them all
okay like it's just winning in this
position connected pawns are just better
Andrew k 5 verse was strange but I don't
know maybe it was it was bad anyway
time morning now I can take the airport
check check check check check check
check check check
white forfeits on time whoo hmm yo this
was lucky but I need some luck once in a
while yeah yeah I was just a pawn down
for for nothing and then he played this
really weird move f3 which got me
somehow back end in this game here he
just needs to take you for me this is so
something for what I did yeah not sure
how how much it really is but it's
sometimes what you should do I mean this
I don't know I mean obviously played
some moves that are bad i'm making
before is just clearly bad because it
just loses started licking as around
here i'm starting to get to have the
more more dangerous pawns the computer
says is finding drawers for white but
it's not easy at all here it's losing is
so that is too much him it's too much
yeah can I need to look up this opening
I keep getting this line once in a while
and I always forget what what to do
exactly Luke yet you can play Queen b3m
yeah this is a rookie yet it's just a
total lemon I need to do something else
here computer suggestion suggests h6
yeah why not good one Bishop g5 is the
threat just wants to play age six to
prevent that yeah something something
like that I mean I need to look this up
this has really harmless reputation but
we can see if you play something like
that you can get yourself into trouble
or queen here's probably better checking
both pawns yeah this would have been
very embarrassing okay thanks for
watching